alors euh moi personnellement à le faire
moi personnellement je n'en referai pas
parce que ça m'a énormément traumatisé
que je me suis acceptée telle que je
suis mais je suis pas là pour dire aux
autres de ne pas le faire après je pense
que il faut vraiment faire de la
prévention et leur dire d'aller chez des
médecins esthétiques donc c'est à dire
que pas forcément aller sur les réseaux
sociaux etc pourquoi pas aller sur des
sites comme doctolib c'est vraiment
agréé voilà et même par rapport à la
dysmorphophobie vraiment qu'elles en
parlent en fait qu'elles aillent chez
des médecins pour parler de ça et pas
direct alors juste docteur est-ce que
vous vous dites à des jeunes oui on peut
le faire ou bien voilà des personnes qui
veulent le faire oui on peut le faire
c'est efficace et vous voilà il y a si
c'est bien pris en charge si c'est bien
fait vous risquez pas grand chose est-ce
que ça vous le dit ou pas du tout oui
alors on peut faire chez les jeunes il
faut savoir quelle est la limite qu'on
met aux jeunes il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui en dessous de 18 ans de
toute façon il y a maintenant un
règlement de l'Union européenne qui
interdit de le faire même sur les plus
âgés qui veulent le faire est-ce que et
qui nous est-ce que vous dites ces
catastrophique ou est-ce que on peut le
faire si c'est bien encadré si c'est
bien fait et ça va vous rendre peut-être
voilà ça va ça va faire que vous avez
c'est une pratique qu'on fait depuis 40
ans sans problème donc il y a pas de il
y a bien sûr il peut y avoir des
complications mais on n'avait pas c'est
complications graves ici de des
injections pourquoi on les a maintenant
mais parce que sur les réseaux sociaux
ce sont développés ces injelectricités
illégales et que les jeunes vont voir
ces injelectricités illégales et si je
peux vous dire quelque chose aux jeunes
il y a cinq arrêts de flags il y a 5
drapeaux rouges quand vous allez sur les
réseaux la première chose c'est que un
médecin il a un nom et un prénom si vous
arrivez sur un compte sur il y a
beaucoup de médecins sur Nagui
si vous voyez voilà juste un prénom donc
ça c'est un problème un médecin il a non
et un prénom un médecin il a une adresse
professionnelle si vous êtes obligé de
passer par MP pour avoir l'adresse il y
a un problème un médecin il a un cabinet
avec un numéro de téléphone fixe
d'accord parce que pour avoir une ligne
fixe il faut donner une pièce
d'identités avec un nom et un prénom ça
ce sont déjà trois red flags énormes
ensuite un médecin il s'appelle docteur
c'est pas cosmétologue ou praticien
c'est en général c'est de pas c'est pas
en général c'est un médecin c'est
docteur et le dernier Red Flag si on
vous oblige je dis bien vous oblige à
payer de façon autre que par carte
bancaire ou par chèque c'est qu'il y a
un problème une activité ou une on ne
prend ni les cartes bancaires ni l'échec
c'est a priori une activité qui n'est
pas légale c'est bien ça vous faites
référence au docteur Castel
vous auriez opéré vous Sarah si elle
était venue vous voir
mademoiselle vous êtes ravissante c'est
pas la peine vous l'aurez dissuadé au
contraire vous l'auriez opéré malgré
tout avec ses réticences j'aurais
d'abord discuté avec elle pour
comprendre quelles sont ses motivations
pourquoi elle le fait elle m'aurait dit
j'ai bien compris que vous faisiez pour
aller sur Netflix j'aurais dit est-ce
que vraiment c'est pertinent on vous a
choisi là tel que vous êtes est-ce que
vous avez vraiment envie d'aller
rajouter est-ce que vraiment c'est
l'image que vous avez envie de donner
donc déjà on aurait discuté et puis
après si vraiment elle avait voulu et
j'aurais certainement pas injecté 4
litres dans les lèvres peut-être voilà
peut-être Delphine est-ce que vous avez
déjà pensé à faire ça
non non jamais en revanche je pense que
ce qui est bien en préventif c'est
d'aller faire des des massages du visage
il y a plein de facialistes aujourd'hui
qui rebooste le visage donc du coup en
faisant des massages ça permet au
collagène naturel de la peau d'être
boostée après c'est vrai que je trouve
ça triste quand on est jeune de faire
des injections mais bon apparemment
c'est un modèle
de gens qui ont des complexes et qui
veulent les corriger aussi on le voit
bien dans le cas de Mademoiselle que en
fait avant les injections enfin les
enfin elle est beaucoup mieux d'avoir
les injections
voilà quelqu'un dont c'est véritablement
le métier même si c'est un peu plus cher
et même si ça retarde éventuellement une
éventuelle opération il vaut mieux
mettre un peu de côté régulièrement et
se faire faire une intervention
peut-être un an plus tard mais au moins
bien sûr elle en fait elle a été voir
elle est docteur
ils ont une clinique et voilà ils ont
une clinique
par rapport aux 5 red flag que je vous
ai dit il y a rien il y avait ni un nom
prénom il y avait ni un docteur
en fait c'était un nom sur sur Instagram
il y a un business c'est ça il y a des
chirurgiens notamment enfin des
charlatans qui viennent de l'étranger
qui loue des parties de cliniques ou des
instituts de beauté et qui s'installent
de manière tout à fait illégale ce sont
pas des ravageurs
il y a des charlatans encore une fois
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière
j'ai vu une patiente qui s'était fait
injecter par une cosmétologue
russe entre guillemets qui travaillait
chez une esthéticienne
des appartements Airbnb Airbnb
aujourd'hui c'est deux c'est 60 euros ça
leur revient quand elle a une injection
et ensuite elles font payer 200 euros
donc en une journée ou quoi
mais non mais je me suis renseigné sur
ce business parce que moi ça me rend
malade et ça j'avais pensé à faire un
truc
il y avait du boulot pour toi
mademoiselle qui doit le faire voilà
mais ce qui a vraiment changé c'est
qu'en fait avant on venait pour une
hypocution parce qu'on avait un nez
comme ça maintenant on vient on veut
être la version
plus de soi-même et ce qui est quand
même très hypocrite c'est que là il
vient d'avoir un nouveau filtre bol de
l'amour qui va qui va être encore plus
formidable et tout ça et voilà et on
incite encore les jeunes alors on est là
en train de pleurer sur des dérapages et
puis on continue à accepter ces filtres
ça devrait plus pas exister ça devrait
être interdit pour être obligatoire
c'est jeune femme qui font ça des deux
fausses injections elles gagnent jusqu'à
700 euros par jour donc 15000 euros par
mois et ma question c'est est-ce que
puisque c'est légal de son procurer et
puisqu'elle joue sur les mots qu'elles
sont pas surgènes les cosmétologues
est-ce qu'elles sont dans l'illégalité
est-ce pourquoi elles sont pas
condamnées s'il y a 300000 personnes qui
les suivent et que tout le monde le sait
au final il y a pas 300000 personnes qui
les suivent il y a 300000 followers
c'est 10 euros les 10000 followers on
reçoit des des sollicitations tous les
jours pour en acheter donc 300000
followers c'est pour ça coûte 300 euros
enfin les gens les connaissent un peu
quand même qu'est-ce
de la médecine aujourd'hui il y a deux
esthéticiennes à Rennes qui ont été
condamnés pour de l'exercice illégal
d'amitié à des peines de prison et une
interdiction de professionnels n'ont pas
le droit à plus le droit d'exercer la
profession d'esthéticienne pendant 3 ans
je crois donc bien sûr et c'est aussi de
la tromperie en matière de santé ça
c'est beaucoup plus grave ce qu'on
appelle la tromperie en matière de santé
et ça c'est des peines qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à 7 ans de prison et plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'amende